[موسيقى]
بطبيعه الحال لان هذا خبر صادم ومؤلم
ويعني نحن كمسلمين ايضا نحتسب ونصبر
ونرجو من الله سبحانه وتعالى
وندعوه
يعني حقيقه العائله يعني متاثره جدا جدا
بهذا الامر وانا شخصيا ايضا تاثرت به لان
هذا شقيقي يعني ومهما كان الانسان فهو
يتعلم
لاحكام مثل هذه الاحكام الظالمه على
الاخرين فكيف اذا كان لشقيقه
نعمل يعني اساس القبض هو انه كان يغرد من
حساب
في تويتر اللي هو منصه الان
وكان يغرد بحساب يعني غير معروف
وايضا جهاز غير المملوك له
وبشريحه ليست له
ومع ذلك استطاعوا
بالتتبع الالكتروني ان يصلوا اليه وان
يقبضوا عليه بناء على هذه التقريرات
محدوده جدا والذين يتابعونه ايضا عدد لا
يتجاوز العشره بحال والتغريدات لم
يرتوت لها احد ولم يعني تنال اعجاب احد
الحساب الذي في تويتر مجهول وشقيقي ايضا
شخص غير معروف
وغير معروف باي نشاط عام ولا مشهور باي
نشاط لا نشاط الدعوي ولا خيري ولا سياسي
ولا حقوقي ولا شيء من هذا القبيل
ثم التغريدات التي كتبها بعضها عن لبن
المراعي وبعضها الاشياء يعني بسيطه يعني
فيها نقد للدوله لكن يعني نقد ليس بذلك
النقد الذي
يوجب مثل هذه الحمله او مثل هذا الاعتقال
البوليسي والهجوم عليه واخذه من بيته
فلما يعني كانت هذه هي اصل القضيه وهذا هو
سبب الاعتقال
يعني
استنتجت ان
القبض عليه ليست لم تكن له اي مبررات
من عمله هو
واذا كان هناك مبرر فهو مبرر بسيط ووسخيف
ايضا
اذا لماذا قبضوا عليه
اظن اظن الراجحا بان القبض عليه هو من اجل
النكايه والايذاء لشخصيا باعتبار ان نشاطي
مفتوحه في العالم على الاجهزه والاعلام
وعلى المنصات التواصل وغير ذلك من الامور
وايضا على المنظمات الحقوقيه فيما يتعلق
بقضايا الاعتقال والقمع الموجوده في بلدنا
[موسيقى]
لما اخذوه
بسبب هذه التقليدات البسيطه ازلوه في سجن
انفرادي ثم بعد ذلك حققوا معه
واستدرجوه بوعود من الضباط بان يعني
المساله بسيطه تعطينا رايك في بعض
المعتقلين والمسجونيين
وهذا الامر لن يترتب عليه شيء فسالوه طبعا
سالوه عن المشايخ المعتقلين الشيخ عوض
القرني الشيخ سلمان عوده الشيخ صقر
الحوالي الشيخ علي العمري الشيخ دحدح
وسالوه عني انا طبعا شقيقه شخصيه فاثنى
على الجميع وانهم يعني اناس فيهم خير
ومرادهم نفع البلد هو مصلحه البلد
وانهم يعني لا يعرف عنهم اي سوء ولا اي
ارهاب ولا شيء من هذا القبيل
وهذا يعني سجلوه
سجلوا هذه القضايا كنقطه ادانا له بانه
يدعم الشخصيات الارهابيه ويدعم الشخصيات
المعتقله بتهمه الارهاب
انا بالنسبه للتواصل الشخصي معه انا من
2000 2014 الف
لم اتصل به شخصيا ولم اسمع صوته ولم يكن
بيننا وبيني وبينه اي مراسلات على الاطلاق
صدقا وحقا يعني ولو كان هذا الامر حاصل
لذكرته في السابقه في اثناء السجن
الانفرادي منع عنه الدواء لانه مصاب بداء
في المخ ومنع عنه للدواء فتره لانه لابد
ان ياخذه منذ ان كان صغيرا ياخذ هذا
العلاج
وبعد الحاح منه يعني صراخ منه عليهم اتوا
له بالدواء لهذا الداء لكن هناك ادواء
اخرى لم يعطوه علاجات لها الان يعني وضعه
صحي طيب هو ياخذ العلاج هذا
وبعد ان خرج للسجن الجماعي يعني خرج من
الزنزانه الانفراديه التي اوذي فيها وسببت
له
كابه وسببت له يعني ضغط نفسي كبير جدا اما
الان فهو مع المساجين في السجن العام
ولكثرتهم يعني استطاع ان يجد مجتمعا واسعا
جدا يتحدث معهم ويلتقي بهم